[Music]
let's go to donna in philly what up
donna how are we doing
hi john what's up
no not much i'm a dog lover
are you a dog lover are you a dog parent
because i'm a dog lover i'm a i'm a dog
parent of three oh no
no
tell me all about them where'd they come
from what are their names
all that's right
rusty ripley and spencer
what happened to spencer why did he get
an r name
well because he wasn't supposed to be
mine
ooh you're a dog parent kidnapper dude i
like where this is i am i am that's a
whole there's a whole like podcast sub
genre below murder podcast our parent
podcast yeah and then pet parent thieves
podcast yes
yes no he was supposed to be my dog my
daughter's service dog it didn't work
out cause he didn't like men
so i got him
dang
that's a whole nother show
yeah
how's rusty i had an awesome friend
named rusty one of the greatest guys
i've ever known um
how's what kind of dog is rusty rusty is
a cockapoo all three of them are
cockapoos oh just cocker spaniel poodle
yeah all your dogs look the same that's
even more creepy hey
do you remember in seinfeld they had
that horse named rusty they kept farting
all the time that was awesome yeah
anyway excellent
rusty does too
there must be something with the name no
my friend rusty he didn't he never did
that he's just awesome guy um
okay so
pet parent pet parent you don't have one
of those uh tricycle motorcycles do you
no i don't have a trike do you listen to
rush
no okay now we're back now we're back
all right so what's up alrighty i'm
calling because i have a question
regarding work issue all right bring it
on all right
my supervisor left about a year ago to
go on
leave
and then her replacement went out in
march
so they asked me to fill in temporarily
through the supervisor role i didn't
want to do it had no desire was happy
where i was was like nope don't want it
personally really didn't think like i
could do it
i actually like the job of course you do
you're a pet mom of course you do
surprisingly i've actually enjoyed doing
what i'm doing well now that it's been
over a year our handbook says that once
they're out a year their position
isn't held for them they stole the job
in our department
but not necessarily the job that they
were in before okay
management just came to me since it's
been a year and asked me if i wanted the
job permanently
so i said yes
the problem here is did you not tell
your friend
she's also my friend oh no that's my
question
pet parents it always ends up pet
parents
should i tell her yes that's your fault
yes man but i asked management and they
were like we'll tell her when we know
she's coming back because they're
they're not sure that she's gonna come
back
okay so
do you still talk to your friend
i do actually when kelly called me she
was on the phone with me
i don't want to be rude but you're the
worst okay so she
yeah i know
so hold on so you and i'm smiling when i
said that you're not really lost i mean
you kind of are but um so
i feel like i am i mean your feelings
are correct your feelings are correct
but so
does your friend like talking about when
she's going to come back and she can't
wait and she's just getting healthy
she's getting healthy because she keeps
saying it's going to be another month
it's going to be another now maybe
january she's looking at
and she knows she knows the rules i know
she knows the rules but you're her
friend
why did she leave what's the medical
issue
i really didn't want to get into that
she's got a bunch of health issues and
all different things okay but she
she doesn't know she's actually going to
be able to come back stress and her body
and how it reacts to stress and all that
but
every time she calls she's always like
how's work and
she was really great in the beginning
when i took the job she was like helping
me i could call her at any time i still
feel like i could call her any time but
now she every time she calls she's like
so how's work you haven't been calling
me everything must be going pretty good
and i'm like yeah and they try to avoid
the subject
yeah you gotta i know you gotta get it i
know i should tell her yes
okay so how do i
tell her what is it about y'all's
relationship that you don't tell her
because i'm i'm trying to just imagine
in my head
um
like i'm just trying to i'm picking like
i'm trying todd my buddy todd and we're
working the same place we actually
worked at the same university for a
season and then he goes out for a year
now i'm thinking out loud here if he was
dying of cancer and he's on cancer leave
and slowly is working his way back
and then i swoop in and take his job and
i don't tell him i'm just like
and then he comes back two months after
the year or six months or whatever
dude okay
now i'm also thinking if he is out with
you know
a unspecified psychiatric issue like
burnout like i just can't come back
right now i'm gonna take medical leave
and there's just like amorphous
um
my knees hurt and my back hurts and my
neck's got problems and i can't sit at a
computer whatever
but we would have been having that
conversation i don't know i my
friendships are just different and so i
don't know if your friendship is one
that's pretty close
there's something about that you're not
gonna tell her because i would just have
had this conversation months ago
i i think we're not
close friends we it's more of a work
friendship like we talk about things
that happen at work i mean i do talk to
her about you know my girls and my dogs
oh jeez do you have human kids too by
the way
do you have human kids too
i do i have two girls
oh see a regular parent do they know
that they are never mind that's a whole
other
okay you know what so
at the end of the day yes
you've got to have this conversation
here's where it's going to be you're
going to be in a pickle as if your
business says you cannot do that this is
an hr issue you cannot have this
conversation have they said that to you
they didn't say that but they said that
they would discuss it with her when they
knew she was coming back
so that's where i'm kind of like
if i tell her am i going to get in
trouble with work if i don't tell her is
our friendship going to be kind of weird
and then the other part is when she
comes back
how do we work together if i have her
job
so
reverse engineering your question
let that happen when that happens
okay
because now you're going to start okay
here's two things you're going to do the
first thing you're doing is you're going
to start catastrophizing because you're
on shaky relational ground so you're
going to start imagining a scene i'm
definitely doing that yes and you're
you're having a bunch of imaginary pre
conversations
and then what happens is you imagine her
saying something and then you imagine
these awesome comebacks that you have
and then your body spins up and goes
into war because that's all it knows how
to do and so you're literally killing
yourself
and i'm not i'm not smiling anymore like
you're literally driving yourself crazy
no you're absolutely right
i literally there's nights i can't sleep
because i'm this conversation keeps
going on in my head yes and then
what you're starting to do is to
minimize your relationship with her
so it went from we're good friends to we
just talk about dogs and kids we're just
like a work friend so you're going to
continually squash that relationship and
minimize it whereas what's happening in
her world is you're her only lifeline
yeah i feel like so it is inflating on
her side
she's probably over dramatizing how
close y'all are
and okay you are you were just
you're piling coal in your engine and
it's just gonna make the train wreck
bigger when it finally happens
and so
all of this and this is this is me
now talking to all the listeners
all of this gets headed off early
if we have conversations early on hey
they just asked me to be the interim
this is going to be weird
let's talk about it now like if they
offer me this full-time job i don't want
it and then a month in like hey i really
like this i'm loving this i know it's
going to be weird for us it's just
putting all that out there this is the
same conversation i never talked about
any of that when i first took it over
she was yes so really helpful but never
really discussed how that would affect
our our friendship yes and so there's
only one way forward and it's directly
in the middle of it
and just to lean in and probably in
person if at all possible
and do you all hang out ever do you all
go to get a drink or have coffee or
anything
every once in a while
oh my gosh y'all are in person
yes yes and so here's your way forward
take her out yup
and say i should have been having this
conversation with you a long time ago
i'm so sorry here's where we are and if
you're mad i totally get it if you are
upset i totally get it or if you're
excited for me i totally get it but
here's the situation
right like i feel like it'll she'll put
up a good front but internally she's
gonna
take it really hard well and that's not
your job
um
your job isn't to manage how she hears
this it's to be hospitable and kind and
own up i should have been having this
conversation with you a long time ago
and i didn't
right
yeah
hate i i hate this for you i mean i just
hate it for it i know it's a messy
situation it's just so
awkward and if she's got any sort of
psychological issues that she stepped
away for i i imagine that will make this
that will compound this challenge
um if she's coming back with
any
it may be a gift let's let's do the
optimistic side she may be stressed on i
don't know how to come back as a
supervisor
and it may be a gift probably not but we
can maybe make it that way i don't know
but yes there's only one way forward and
that is to have this direct conversation
okay cool will you let me know how that
goes
sure
awesome i can't i can't i literally
can't wait but yes
hug rusty and spencer the the night
before
okay and they'll give you
pet parent superpowers or something like
that probably not but um good for you
but yeah it's time you got to have that
conversation [ __ ] had a while ago but
here we are so let's just move forward
and let's have it and let's be
remorseful you know that you should have
been having this conversation and you
know it's going to be awkward and for
everybody out there
not having hard conversations is just
like spending out of your checking
account and never checking the balance
there will come a moment
when the late fees start rolling in and
it will be brutal you're better off not
buying the salad skipping dinner
not buying that gift than paying five
dollars for a cup of coffee and then
paying 150 in late fees
similar to hard conversations at work
with your spouse with your girlfriend or
boyfriend have the conversation god help
us all
come on donna you have to rep parent pet
parents better than that